today I'm shopping with Alex because he
needs food for the week and I'm going to
talk about seven ways to win as an
introvert high note
at all people people don't know that
about me yeah yeah I am like after I'm
done teaching this class I need to
compress so I'm like completely
exhausted I don't have a cool what's up
two or three days where I'll be at home
and like I don't need to talk to anybody
where I do shine more around people
can't put out in the box so one of
things I get a lot from my viewers and
subscribers and viewers is that people
feel like they need to be outgoing you
need to be a type-a personality to have
success in the business and I get it cuz
you see the shark tank guys and you see
Cuba and you see the guys with bravado
who are out there making a name for
themselves and you feel like well if I'm
gonna have success I need to be like
those people and what I want to tell you
is those guys are doing them and they're
having success because they're going
all-in on their strengths and so I'm
gonna here with you the seven ways that
you can have success as an inch
so number one is stop trying to be an
extrovert you gotta be proud of who you
are and go all in on their strengths
there's a story that we had on the
channel not that long ago where was an
Indian entrepreneur talking about a
bunny and a bunny came home from school
on this report card and he got an a-plus
and hopping but like a C or D in
swimming
it's those parents were super upset
about that and immediately enrolled him
into swimming classes and had to get
better at swimming and he worked hard I
got better and every day slowly got
better at swimming and it eventually
came home and got like a B or B minus or
something like that on the report card
and so the parents were so happy and
then all the while he forgot how to hop
and what's a bunny meant to do is hop
right and so you will only have success
by going in on their strengths
understand what you're good at and play
to those instead of trying to be
something you're not as long as you're
chasing somebody else's expectations
what you're supposed to be instead of
your own as long as you're living up to
what like you think you're supposed to
be to be a success then decide we're
going to work out for you and so it's
understanding what you're good at and
going all-in on that and not caring so
much about how other people are choosing
their success
so time to that is number two play To
Your Strengths if I use myself as an
example
I am very introverted and that probably
doesn't come out a lot on this channel
people are surprised when they hear that
about me but I massively need time to
decompress when I'm around others I can
come alive and be myself but then I need
to have a long time I need to I need to
break I don't I don't like being around
people all the time I don't talk to the
guy next to me on the airplane I never
go to networking events even if it can
help my business I don't go to
networking events I got a great
opportunity to go to a networking event
the other day and I said you know what I
don't like networking events and I'm not
trying to work on fixing it because I
don't care because instead I play to
what I'm really good at and so instead
of going to an event and being in the
crowd and you're hosting a booth or
whatever it is I'm the guy who goes
onstage and does the speaking and then
people come up to me afterwards I'm much
better at the marketing side than the
sales side I'm not the guy who's picking
up the phone and calling people all day
long and trying to sell them on my
product or service I'm knowing who
creates an environment with people then
find me and want to call me and do
business with me and so playing to my
strengths really helps and played
if you are not a knock against the
people who are extroverted go in and do
what you do play To Your Strengths
whatever they are that's where you're
gonna find real success
number three is model success you know
whenever I don't know how to do
something my favorite thing to do is go
out and find somebody who's done it and
model what they did to have success Alex
is buying we're buying it spinach first
step listen healthy spinach so one name
that comes to mind for me is Ellen Ellen
claims that she's an introvert and when
I saw that video we mentioned her in our
top ten I was actually really shocked by
that because you think of Alan you don't
see someone who is introverted but but
she is she's in a field that's dominated
by extroverts for the most part right if
you look at the people who are comedians
or talk-show hosts from the most part
they love being around filming a video
for my youtube channel
really yeah all right I'm at TDS they
got kicked out a Loblaws for filming
because I've worried about what's gonna
show up on Yelp from people's reviews
the way to get negative reviews is to
kick the people out who can influence
the reviews anyway it doesn't only make
a lot of sense but it's all good so
talking about modeling success right
Allen is this person who's extremely
introverted and I you know respected a
lot of her coming out and telling her
story and I'm just gonna set up for the
videos for the day and so finding people
that you look up to who can share their
stories who are introverts and building
that model up where you can look at what
they've done learn from their success
like if you're if you're an introvert
doesn't mean you can't have success in
comedy doesn't mean you can't have
success as a talk show host right
doesn't mean you can't have success as a
speaker it doesn't mean you can't have
success in the things that we
traditionally associate with extroverted
people just means you have to play the
game a little bit differently and play
it your way and so whenever you don't
know what to do find someone who has
done it and models of success and apply
it to your situation to increase the
chances of you making it
number four is create an environment for
success
once you discover the things that you
need to do the the mentors that you are
following the habits that you need to
put in place it's important that you
create a system and a routine so that
it's consistent because it's easy to get
motivated watch Ellen one day and then
you're off and running and you think
everything's great but then the next day
you wake up and all that motivation is
gone and so you need to build that into
your daily habits your daily practice
your morning routine what are you doing
every morning to read a story about
something that inspires you don't want
to be great at what you do to go chase
your dream and it's especially important
when all the messages are against what
you're trying to do you know when the
people are friends or family in your
life are telling you that you can't have
success doing something and it's often
those people closest to us who don't
believe in us oddly enough at the start
so you have to figure out a way to make
it something that you do every single
day that motivation that charge that you
felt watching the video listen to that
audio book and you know reading that
article that charge that you felt you
have to incorporate into your daily
structure your daily routine so that you
get it every single day so you are
building up the foundation for your
success and it's not some accidental
thing that happens once in a while but
you're planning for you
pairing for you're expecting it every
single day that really dramatically
improves a chance of your success so
think about your environment think about
your physical space right think about
what you're doing your your business
think about your habits and your morning
routines and pop that in so that you are
setting yourself up for success every
single day
number five is follow your passion this
is important for any anybody who's
trying to do anything you got to follow
your passion when you are following your
passion you will find a new level that
you didn't know existed or you might
think I'm super extroverted my
excitement comes out guys when I'm
talking about entrepreneurship when I'm
hanging out entrepreneurs if I'm talking
about entrepreneurship the Toronto Blue
Jays
you know salsa dancing League of Legends
maybe a handful of the things I can get
excited about it I can I can find a new
level and it's not faking it and it's
not trying to be somebody I'm not you
know it's it's Who I am like I can be
animated and even though I don't like
being around people in social settings
you know all the time I could talk to
entrepreneurs all day long all day long
and try to fix your business all day
long look that fuels me when you find
the thing that you're passionate about
it helps you find a new gear finally the
level in yourself it helps you push
through limiting beliefs it helps you
break through your comfort zones and do
things that you never thought you'd be
able to do and so whether that's as an
entrepreneur as a you know as a in a job
that you're chasing in a relationship
anything like you have to find that
passion for what you're doing to have
success and so hopefully you found that
with what you're doing and if not then
you know waking up every day and doing
something that you hate is not the
answer you've got to be exploring trying
until you find the thing that you're so
jazzed up about that you you know want
to dedicate an insane amount of time to
perfecting and make you better
number six is don't use it as a crutch
you want to embrace your introverted
miss but find success your way where I
think a lot of people will then will say
well I can't do this so I won't do this
because that's only what actually what
do people do or I won't have success
because I'm an introvert just like the
people who say I won't have success
because I you know I don't have the
right family or I didn't go to school I
don't have any money I'm in the wrong
country or whatever it is like whatever
reason right a lot of people feel like
they won't have success because they're
introverted if you want to be a speaker
you don't have to be massively outgoing
to be a great speaker there's lots of
speakers who are introverted there's
lots of entrepreneurs who are
introverted you look at the the list of
the richest entrepreneurs most of them
you've never even heard of because their
model isn't to boil and be a public
speaker and make a big name for
themselves they just quietly do their
thing and so whatever it is that you
want to do there's a way to do it
without having to use it as a crutch you
still need to push yourself this is not
an excuse for you to stop driving
because now you realize you're an
introvert and that's okay this isn't
this isn't a negative thing you know if
you're an introvert where that is a
badge of honor and go out and drive and
push and get better and look for ways to
consistently do something that's that's
challenging yourself and so don't ever
ever ever use anything as a crutch if
you didn't get to where you want to be
it's you it's your fault you didn't try
hard enough you're not prepared enough
you're not good enough yet you can get
better and so when you ask yourself why
can't I be a successful fill in the
blank or why haven't I had the success
that I want yet at fill in the blank you
look yourself in the mirror and ask
yourself why you can't be a success
whatever answer comes back that's the
belief that you need to crush that's the
crutch that you need to get rid of you
are not as far ahead as you want to be
and it's nothing to do with you being an
introvert or not because you're not
hustling enough you're not pushing your
limiting beliefs enough you're not
driving forward now so don't ever ever
ever use the fact that you are
introverted as a crutch for not getting
to where you want to go it's a badge of
honor be proud
we're not excited there and number seven
is find your one word and this might
sound self-serving because I have a book
called coming out about your one word
but what I found is whether it's through
your one word or through some other
mechanism you need to have
self-awareness you need to understand
what you stand for what you will
tolerate what you won't tolerate any
longer and having that self-awareness
gives you confidence to say yes and no
to certain things that make important
decisions in your life so as an example
this school is about family the school
is one word is family that means that we
need to be inclusive that means we need
to be welcoming that means we need to
make people feel like they belong when
they come here that adjusts a lot of the
decision-making that we make here as a
school you know there's a lot of people
who who are out there that maybe better
salsa dancers than us and a lot of
people out there who are great salsa
dancers a lot of them are really snobby
a lot of them won't dance with a
beginner student because they feel like
it's beneath them because all they
haven't you know they're not they're not
gonna be fun for me to dance with and it
could be easy to get sucked down into
that thinking that we need to get better
or that oh maybe I shouldn't maybe
actually dance with more advanced
dancers maybe I shouldn't pay attention
to the beginner dancers maybe that's not
you know the right way to do it and as
soon as people start casting doubt on
you right as soon as people tell you you
should be doing this and not that if you
don't have a strong center if you don't
have a sense of purpose and a sense of
clarity if you don't know what you stand
for as a human being
forget about being an entrepreneur if
you don't have that sense of confidence
in knowing what you're all about then
you'll fall for anything right if you
don't stand for something you will fall
for anything and that's a problem for a
lot of people and so when you have the
self-awareness to know what you're all
about for me it's belief or TDS is
family for you it's whatever it is
figuring out that one word makes a big
difference so now when you run up
against people who don't believe the
same things as you you don't want to
hang around them right I don't want to
hang around the salsa snobs who feel
like they're too good for everybody else
because that's the opposite of what
we're all about here at TDS we're about
family and community and connectivity
and so somebody doesn't believe in that
does
have a you know won't enjoy being here
and I don't want them influencing what
we do here either and so if you don't
have that awareness for yourself then
you'll continually feel like you're
making the wrong decisions continually
doubt yourself continue lay into the
pressures that other people put upon you
to be better to do something differently
and I hope that that you can break free
so those are my seven tips my seven ways
that you can have success in business in
life as an introvert I'm curious what
did you guys think did you like this
video did you like this style a little
bit different style than I usually do
these a little more ad hoc and impromptu
so let me know what you thought what was
your favorite point leave it down in the
comments below
did I miss something is there an 8 9 10
that you guys want to add or contribute
I'd love to hear your thoughts leave in
the comments thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
you're one where it is and I'll see you
soon